DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there.
I'm Daniel Sieberg with
Google Developers
Live here at I/O 2013.
And I'm joined right now by
Peter Hazlehurst and Nik Sathe
from the Google Wallet team.
Before we get into some of the
announcements that are
happening here at the show, why
don't you guys tell me a
little bit about what you do.
First of all, I know that you
have different roles, in some
ways, but you work together.
So tell me, first of all,
Peter, what you do.
PETER HAZLEHURST: Sure, so I
run the product side for
Google Wallet.
So my team's job is to build
all the great apps, things
like NFC Wallet on your phone.
And the new thing we just
launched, Pay By Gmail.
NIK SATHE: And my role, I'm
part of the engineering
organization.
I try to keep Peter and his
team honest, in some ways.
I'm mostly focused on the
merchant and developers side
of the capabilities that
[? we build. ?]
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK, great.
So let's dive right in to some
of the announcements.
What is new with
Google Wallet?
And what, in particular, was
announced here at the show?
PETER HAZLEHURST: So at the show
today and yesterday, we
announced three new things.
First of all we announced our
instant buy STK for Android.
And that allows developers to
make easy checkout options for
their apps for things like
physical goods and services.
And the second thing we launched
was also our new
Wallet Object APIs, so the
ability to add things to the
Google Wallet like boarding
passes, tickets, loyalty
cards, offers, things
like that.
And then the third thing we
announced, which was really
exciting, was our ability to
attach money in Gmail.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right, now we're
going to get into some
of those a little bit more.
But tell me, are you thinking
about expanding Google Wallet
into a platform, in a
sense, beyond just
what it is right now?
PETER HAZLEHURST: Yes.
So what we're really shooting
for is to try and broaden
Google Wallet so that it's no
longer just tied to something
that you do on your phone.
It works across everywhere
at Google.
So whether you're buying a
subscription on YouTube or
paying for your new Google
music through--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETER HAZLEHURST: --all
access pass.
All of those things are
powered by the Wallet.
So one time you add your credit
card or your bank
account to Google, and you
can use it everywhere.
So that's the whole focus of
everything we're doing.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And how much
of a challenge is that to
integrate all of
those different
services and devices together?
I mean this is obviously
something you guys
think about a lot.
PETER HAZLEHURST: It's been a
really interesting challenge
because we've had a lot of
different teams at Google with
their different going-to-market
strategies and
different ways of wanting to
charge people's cards and
stuff like that.
Plus, we also wanted to
make sure it works on
all sorts of devices.
And that's been a real growth
opportunity for us.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right, Nik
tell us about Google Wallet
Instant Buy.
What is that all about?
I mean I think the name
obviously suggests what it
does, but talk to me about some
of the partners that are
launching as part of that.
NIK SATHE: Sure, so what we saw
was that the Play Store
does a great job of allowing
application developers on
Android to monetize in
app digital content.
But there really wasn't a good
solution for merchants that
were actually selling physical
goods on Android apps and
other capabilities.
Increasingly, we've seen this
is not just online merchants
with an app, but even people
like Uber, one of our launch
partners, where are you complete
the transaction and
pay for it on your phone even
though the goods and services
are actually delivered in
the physical world.
So we're seeing a lot of those
sorts of crossover use cases,
and those are the merchants
that we believe can really
benefit from Instant Buy.
From a merchant's standpoint,
one of the biggest problems
with conversion in mobile
checkout has
been abandonment rates.
Where there's just too many
clicks, too many keystrokes
that you have to enter.
It's a pain in the ass.
And I think that it's one of
those things that all of us
would love to see
happen better.
And we've created a capability
combined with Gplus sign in
the ability to have much,
much fewer clicks.
And we hope that we'll reduce
the abandonment rate from, I
think, it's around 97% according
to one survey that
we recently saw down to
something where it's as little
as a couple of clicks, and
you're right through a
checkout process very easily.
DANIEL SIEBERG: You
mentioned Uber.
And I know a lot of folks in
the Bay Area rely on it.
Even in New York, I know there's
people all over the
country and in the world,
frankly, thinking about how
that ties into their getting
around needs.
And what I've noticed,
to me, it's
almost a no-click situation.
I mean it's so seamless, when
you make that payment, you
forget that you're making
the payment.
Which I think is great.
I mean it removes that kind
of friction or barrier.
And I guess that's a great
example of that.
Are there other partners
you can point to?
NIK SATHE: Yeah, I didn't want
to leave anyone out.
I actually wrote them down.
But we had 11 partners that have
already integrated the
App Store available on the Play
Store to download and use
integrated with Google Wallet,
Airbnb, Booking.com, Expedia,
The Fancy, GoPago, Tagstand,
Uber, Tabbedout, Wrapp,
Priceline, and Rue La La.
So those are the 11
partners that
launched with us yesterday.
A lot of them, actually, are
in this kind of crossover
space where you're making a
reservation online or on your
mobile device, but you're
actually staying in a hotel or
renting a car or whatever
it happens to be in
the physical world.
From a merchant's standpoint,
what they've told us was that
this integration
is really easy.
They don't pay any
new fees to us.
The capability we provide is a
value added service without
charging them.
They still continue to process
their credit card transactions
the same way that they would.
And, hopefully, we'll be able to
show that conversion uplift
with some of our case
studies have
already shown is happened.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So, Peter, let's
move on to Attach Money
in Gmail which was announced
yesterday.
Before we came on the air
here, you mentioned what
somebody had said about
it as an announcement.
What did they say
in terms of the
announcements here at Google?
PETER HAZLEHURST: Yeah, we
got some great feedback.
One of the quotes we got was,
it's the craziest new thing
we've heard at Google
I/O all day.
So that was really exciting.
And I think what we did, which
was kind of fun, is rather
than just blast out a new
feature to everybody, we've
launched it virally.
And the way it works is the only
way you get the feature
is if someone sends you money.
And so to jump start the
ecosystem, we have all the
Googliers in the US, and then
yesterday, I sent $10 to every
one that was at I/O
with a US account.
And so if you have a friend,
and you want access to it,
find someone who's been at I/O,
and it's just going to
grow like this virally.
Until we get really, really
comfortable, and then we'll
make it available
to everybody.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Which was kind
of how Gmail got it's
start in a way too.
PETER HAZLEHURST: Yeah,
they had an
invite model, five users.
That sort of thing.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So walk
me through it.
I mean, earlier we agreed
that you we're
going to send me $1,000.
As I recall--
PETER HAZLEHURST:
That's right.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Just to
demonstrate this.
It hasn't happened yet.
So I don't know if there's
sort of a delay, or--
PETER HAZLEHURST: Actually,
interestingly enough, you
picked $1,000.
We have a whole bunch of really
cool security that's
designed to protect consumers'
accounts.
And one of the things we look
for is really out of the
ordinary things.
And it would have known
that I shouldn't
have sent you $1,000.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Interesting.
PETER HAZLEHURST: And it's
probably just being blocked.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
yeah, sure.
It's being held up
in some way.
But just walk me through
how it works.
PETER HAZLEHURST: So, let me
tell you how it works.
It's deceptively simple.
In Gmail we have the
new compose bar.
And you know down at the
bottom where there is
attachments, so you can attach
a photo or a document or link
something from Gdrive,
that sort of thing.
If you've got access to the
product, you'll just see a
little dollar sign.
Click on dollars, pops up, says
OK, would you like to
send $10, $100, whatever
you want.
As long as you have Google
Wallet, it'll either show you
if you have a balance because
you may have already received
some money before.
And once you add your name,
you'll see a nice, beautiful
Gplus thing so that you can make
sure that you're really
sending it to the person
you expect to.
And then you hit send,
and it's done.
Five seconds later, you're going
to receive the email,
and it's going to say great,
here is $10 from Peter.
If you don't have a Google
Wallet yet, or if you're on
Hotmail or AOL or something like
that, there's a call to
action to go to Google and
get a Google Wallet.
And then the money will
be deposited.
And so there's a little bit of
a process for the first time,
and then after that, it's
all instantaneous.
So if I send it to you, you
get it in one second.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I see.
So it's not tied to somebody
opening the attachment, or
reading the email, or
anything like that.
It's just as soon as you
send it, it's there.
PETER HAZLEHURST:
That's right.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
So who do you think
is going to really
capitalize on using this?
I mean sending money to each
other or friends or something
is one idea.
But from a business standpoint,
where do you think
this is going to lead?
PETER HAZLEHURST: So in the
short term, we focused on the
consumer side.
We had a lot of small businesses
and big businesses
say, hey, can we start putting
merchant stuff through this?
And we were like hey,
hang on guys.
Let's focus on the consumer.
And so our sort of scenarios
that we see a lot of is people
saying, hey, we went out
to dinner last night.
Can you send your share?
Or I'm renting an apartment in
the city for the holidays, you
guys want to chip in?
And all you have to do is reply,
yeah, here's my $50.
And it's frictionless.
It's just built into that social
engagement that Gmail
is really working well on.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
fantastic.
That's really cool.
PETER HAZLEHURST: You can
imagine us sticking it in
other parts of Google services
where there's a lot more of
those interactions.
And so we're going to
work on that over
the rest of the year.
DANIEL SIEBERG: It seems like
a ton of potential for
something like this.
Now Nik, I want to get into the
types of things that you
can store in Wallet because
tell me about all of the
things, I guess, that you
can store in Wallet.
Which leads me to the
question of what can
you store in Wallet?
NIK SATHE: So when we designed
the Wallet Objects API, our
intention was to create a very
flexible data model that
basically allows developers'
imaginations to dictate what
gets stored in the Wallet.
So the basic platform is one
that provides just name value
pairs with some templating
capabilities so you can define
how you want these things
to look and be
stored in the Wallet.
We went one step further than
that for two areas.
The first being loyalty, which
in many cases or memberships
in general, they are the key
engagement vehicle for
merchants to engage with
their consumers.
And the current process
is very broken.
We all have tons of loyalty
memberships, and we don't
really use them because we don't
carry around a stack of
cards like that.
Other than Peter and I who
actually have a second wallet
that has all of our loyalty
memberships, and that's what I
want to get rid of.
And the additional things that
we've focused on in loyalty is
adding some semantic definition
to that object and
some additional capabilities
like leveraging the data that
we already have about a consumer
in their account, in
their Wallet to do
instant sign up.
So a merchant can actually have
their program discovered.
I can walk into the Marriott
down the road, which is where
we're staying, we will, based
on location and timeliness,
surface that as, hey, maybe you
should sign up for Marriott.
If you already have one,
we'll show you the
card that you have.
If you don't have one,
we'll surface it.
And say, hey, sign up today, and
Marriott could offer them
a 1,000 point bonus to sign
up instantaneously.
It's one click, you're done.
And merchants get much, much
better data because in most
cases Wallet accounts have
gone through some loyal
customer validation.
So we have verified data about
a customer, there's no more
Elvis Presley and Mickey Mouse
ending up in people's systems.
And the second area that we've
done more with is offers
where, again, we've added
semantic definitions.
So like one of the fields that
we have is an expiration date
for an offer, and the system
automatically recognizes that
and does alerts and
notifications to consumers
saying, hey, you have a coupon
that's about to expire.
We expected to take those two
types and extend them into
other verticals mostly driven by
the developer community and
what they tell us
is important.
But we'll focus mostly on
commercial objects.
We already have a partner,
BillGuard, that's doing
something very interesting
with the more generic
capabilities that the
platform provides.
Where they have a back end fraud
detection system, you
register your credit cards with
them, and they send you
alerts and actually transaction
records.
And it's actually a very
beautiful interactive
experience right there
in your Wallet.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
And offers also showing up in
the Maps experience too
because people are searching for
pizza or coffee, and they
get that increasingly
suggested to them
as part of the new--
PETER HAZLEHURST:
That's right.
So one of the cool things we
focused on in the Wallet is
making it possible for all
those things you would
normally carry with you, but
either you forget or you just
say, it's not worth it to
carry that gift card.
I'm never going to
use it again.
We let you bring that into the
digital cloud with Google, and
then we'll surface it to you on
your phone or on the web or
in Maps at the right place
and at the right time.
So you never forget that thing
that you had that is going to
create value for you.
And it's this continuous
experience.
And what Nik was talking about
is we're starting off with
some really obvious things like
loyalty cards and offers,
and then as the developer
community grows, we're going
to pick up those key categories
and make them more
first class things
in the Wallet.
Tickets is a really
obvious one.
We've got a lot of interest from
movie theaters and stuff
like that that they want to be
able to have the ticket so
that when you buy it through
Instant Buy online, you can
also then just have the bar
code on your phone.
Well [INAUDIBLE]
you actually come into the movie
theater, scan your bar
code, keep going, don't talk to
anyone, you don't need to
do credit cards.
It's all just magic.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
awesome.
Well, so, we're running
out of time here.
But if people want to learn more
about all of this whether
from the merchant's side
or the consumer's side,
where can they go?
PETER HAZLEHURST: So, I think
our website's up and running
and it's
developers.google.com/commerce.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK, guys, well,
Peter and Nik, thank you
both so much for joining us.
This is some great
information.
PETER HAZLEHURST: We're really
excited and looking forward to
seeing how things grow.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Don't
forget that $1,000.
PETER HAZLEHURST: $1,000,
I'm on it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I'll give
you my Gmail later.
We'll talk.
PETER HAZLEHURST: Great.
Thanks very much.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Thanks guys.
That's going to do it
for now here at
Google Developers Live.
Stay tuned for lots more
content right here.